hay imágenes que quedarán en la historia
y también discursos esta fue la dimisión
de mijail gorbachov previa a la
disolución de la unión soviética fue el
25 de diciembre de 1991 hace 30 años
en esta situación que sigue al
establecimiento de la comunidad de
estados independientes por la presente
dejó de actuar como presidente de la
unión soviética
beijing est un apuesto presidente es
usar en 1985 mijail gorbachov se
convirtió en secretario general del
partido comunista empezó entonces la
paulatina disolución de la urss con las
reformas aperturistas económicas y
políticas como la perestroika y glasnost
con la caída del muro de berlín y las
ansias de independencia de los países
satélite en 1990 gorbachov gana el
premio nobel de la paz y boris yeltsin
es escogido presidente un año después en
1991 en agosto el ala dura del partido
comunista fracasa en un golpe de estado
que acaba desembocando en el fin de la
urss y la independencia de países como
letonia lituania y ucrania así justificó
el colapso gorbachov veinte años después
cubriendo de todo el tiempo la gente
dice que el colapso fue inevitable y yo
todo el tiempo digo que podríamos
mantener la unión pero no la antigua
porque era demasiado burocrática ahora
treinta años más tarde el espectro de la
unión soviética continúa presente en las
calles de rusia el desánimo que siguió a
la caída culminó con el ascenso de
vladimir putin y la vuelta del
autoritarismo por lo que las ansias de
libertad iniciales han sido sustituidas
por la nostalgia de volver a ser una
potencia mundial
nuevos y vivíamos bien en paz en
silencio todo estaba bien porque en el
gobierno había gente que realmente se
preocupaba por nosotros por el país y
luego sólo vinieron traidores gorbachov
arruinó la opción validez ganas tras 69
años de unión soviética cuya disolución
terminó con décadas de disputa con eeuu
dejando un mundo más fragmentado con
espacio para la irrupción de otras
potencias como china y el fin de la
hegemonía comunista